the age of AI is here from Deep learning
to llms to generative AI we live in a
world where AI has the power to
transform just about everything whether
it's handling customer support or
generating code
AI wasn't always so pervasive though the
first AI tools had significant
limitations they couldn't understand
context or learn and improve on their
own
the first chat Bots for example were
rule-based meaning they were developed
based on predefined rules or Scripts
this severely restricted their capacity
to just what was fed into them the same
way any Computing software can only
perform the tasks that it was programmed
to perform
ai-based chat Bots have come a long way
since then they're leveraging
advancements in machine learning and
deep learning capabilities to improve
the understanding of natural language
now with the adoption of llms we're
seeing a new Evolution
large language models use massive
amounts of data and a combination of
deep learning algorithms neural networks
and natural language processing
techniques to generate human-like
responses to queries let's show what
we're talking about with Watson X
assistant a conversational AI platform
designed to build and deploy ai-powered
chatbot with the emergence of generative
AI what's an ex-assistant is working to
transform user experiences and deliver
more intelligent human-like responses
today we'll show you how to leverage
neural seek which is a search in natural
language generation system that will
integrate with Watson X assistant first
we need to set up Watson X discovery
which is where our data will be stored
let's use robotic vacuum manuals as our
example and go into improve and
customize to test it
let's ask how do I change the filter
the answer we get isn't great so let's
try asking it another question
how often should I change the mopping
pad
this time it doesn't answer the question
we were asking at all
to improve our answers let's set up
neural seek to work with Discovery and
assistant
now let's go into the initial setup page
to further fine-tune our extension
we've already pre-filled the initial
information here like what we're talking
about and we've also connected with
Watson discovery
then in the about section it came up
with this paragraph on its own
in tune we're basically seeing how it
should look as well as whether we should
be looking at newer or older documents
and now in Q a this actually looks at
all of our documents and generates some
questions for us to bootstrap our
actions in Watson X assistant
so it's saying that based on this data
we think people are going to be asking
these questions
now click on the integrate tab
from here make note of your API key and
download your custom open API file
now open the Integrations page in Watson
X assistant and click build custom
extension
follow the steps to import your open API
file and click finish
now scroll down and click add on your
neural seek tile to add the extension
follow the steps to set up the
authentication for neural seek
for the authentication type be sure to
set it to API key auth and paste your
neural seek API key from earlier in the
indicated field
click through to finish
now that we've set up our neural seek
extension let's go ahead and add it to
our dialog
first create a new action skill
next we're going to create an action and
quick start with a template before
adding our neural seek starter kit which
we just generated
here you can see we have our neural seek
search action we need to configure it
so you can see that it's generated all
this information for us we need to edit
our extension select the extension we
just created and for the operation we
would like to seek an answer from neural
seek
for parameters we'll set question equal
to query underscore text
click apply and then save the action
now we want to go to no action matches
which means that if we can't match any
of the phrases to anything we've set up
in Watson X assistant it's going to go
out to neural seek and get that answer
for us from Discovery
let's remove the pre-filled text so this
is basically like the anything else node
now let's go to a sub action and go to
neural seek search before hitting apply
then save then preview
let's ask what's an X assistant how do I
change the filter
it's going out to neural seek and here
you can see the response that it's
generated
to change the filter open the filter
door remove the filter by grasping the
tab shake off debris re-insert the
filter and close the filter door replace
the filter every two months
this is a really good and accurate
response
now let's ask our other question how
often should I change the mopping pad
it's going back to neural seek again and
gives us the correct response
as you can see our neural seek extension
can help your chat Bots carry out
conversations just as well as any human
could and that's due to its generative
AI capabilities
to learn more about how you can leverage
generative AI with Watson X assistant
please visit the Watson X assistant page
on ibm.com
thank you if you have questions please
drop us a line below if you want to see
more videos like this in the future
please like And subscribe